the conquest of Mexico yes it took
plagues it took guns it took steel but
as the Spanish admit it would have gone
very differently without languages 1510
Mesoamerica out east you spoke Maya and
lived in a small Kingdom run by its own
real man seriously a local mine leader
was a Halloween eek a real man west of
the Maya many people spoke many
languages from many language families Oh
Tomi Zapotec double-neck but one groups
been taking over you-know-who straight
from the valley of Mexico where the
Triple Alliance you dare not defy us
the Aztecs their empire was built around
on Tibet city-states each one led by
Inglot Dewani the speaker but one al
Tibet stood above the rest denote still
on a huge city floating on a lake home
of high temples human sacrifice and the
Aztec empires waitlet awanee
great speaker the current wait lot on e
is mo Texoma Montezuma you he demands
tribute from all of this area or else or
else flash : their name a start with a
very aztec but make no mistake clash
kala is a proud and independent warrior
state pay up to mo Texoma and rest easy
stay free but constantly watch your back
for a steak obsidian flesh calluses and
bring it I keep saying Aztec but let's
talk names Aztecs means all people from
the legendary homeland Aslan
at least it does in the Aztec language
linguists call that language Nahuatl and
the related peoples are no one but
that's just a way to say speaking
clearly for their part the epic Aztecs
of Aztec empire fame called themselves
America and their land was Michiko
Mexico but while we're over here
debating terminology the bearded men
start to arrive from the yeast and
events unfold that will conspire to put
Nahuatl and maya
into the hands of mexico's conquerors
1511 a shipwreck Spanish crew washes up
on the coast of the Yucatan and is
captured by Mayans two will survive a
jihad a friar and the Sailor Guerrero
Scoob he's the Halloweeny who gave his
name to Tabasco the state and the chili
he battles nearby sheikah Longo and
takes slaves as a reward
among them is Molly nollie an oven girl
who also spoke to Aunt Dahlia the kind
of Mayan in that part of the Gulf Coast
1517 bearded man Cordova lands in the
Yucatan he's greeted warmly and welcomed
by the Maya success nope
turns out it's an ambush the Spanish
retreat but managed to nab a Mayan on
the way out melchidec oh he'll be there
first Mayan translator but a rough one
and one who never buy into this whole
Spain thing 1518 another Explorer
Grijalva takes Melchor hijo to visit tab
scope who trades gifts and tells tales
of a wonderful land of the west with
many more treasures a land called
Michiko the curious Creek Iowa says hmm
maybe I'll stick around a bit but tops
cobs been worn by my analogies guys at
distance and says I think it's time for
you to move along Cuba 1519 this is
where the bearded men have been sailing
from one of them just emptied his life
savings to pay for boats and crew to
explore the fabled riches of Mexico and
non-core des portes sails to Kissimmee
Cozumel and sends out Milt or a hoe to
track down those two shipwreck survivors
the Sailor well he's gone for good not
dead
turns out he went fault lyin seriously
he became a champion warlord but the
other guy Aguila is still alive and his
heart still belongs to Spain the friar
is back in action
Mayan captivity turned Aguila into a
real asset see the Spanish haven't been
big on local languages case in point
they use a word they learned back in
Cuba for every local chief they meet gas
CK you're a Mayan Halloweeny gassy gay a
Mexican plateau an e
Cacique the way 20 of the whole empire
Cacique but not a killer
he speaks John tanmaya now well it's
jump alta outsiders because the Aztec
word jauntily means foreigner we speak
clearly they on the other hand they
speak like foreigners you know what I
mean
the people of Tabasco clearly disagree
because to them it yogathon correct
language whether you call Aguilar speech
foreigner correct Cortez immediately
ceases value keeps him by his side and
makes him his lengua his tongue great
time to talk to more mayans starting
with tub Scoob
but I don't think his towns taking to
the idea of even more bearded men
showing up seriously these guys again no
thanks
they put up quite a fight but with a
little Mayan Intel and a big display of
horse power the Spanish defeat them in
the Battle of sent La tab scroll buries
his dead and hands over a bounty a
bounty that includes that woman tab
scope captured in 1513 milene Ali this
woman has a way with words not only can
she speak with a Gilad she knows the
Mexican language also too many names
Melina Lee took a Spanish name Dona
marina which got translated back into
Nahuatl with an honorific suffix scene
Moline scene that came back into Spanish
as Malinche which is how she's still
remembered in Mexico who got this now
has a strategy he and I allowed speaks
spanish to each other
Aguila turns to Mallinson and speaks
Maya and Mallinson uses Nahuatl with the
Aztecs until she eventually learned
Spanish then sorry Aguilar you're out go
team linguist why the long chain of
communication though why can't a Gilad
just pick up some Aztec because
classical nahuatl chantal Maya come from
two completely distinct language
families it's like Chinese in English
sort of see there's a unique linguistic
mixing that happened in Mesoamerica but
that's so cool I'll save it for another
video
with his linguist always by his side but
this begins to unravel the resentment
beneath the surface see I don't know how
you pictured it but this is not going to
be a small band of Spaniards standing
alone against an empire success hinges
on flipping allies lots and lots of
allies that's where team linguist comes
in Spain flips the book lomax they
downplay infighting and scuttle their
own ships to go all in they learn of
clash kala they dare to enter clash kala
the ferocious slash Collin warriors put
up a major fight but the Spanish
impressed the cacique and earned
themselves a deeply loyal ally against
the mashita the enemy of my enemy is my
Moline Singh flipping towns and
butchering others this allied crew
- tenochtitln knock-knock multix oma
and in November of 1519 well dick soma
opens they enter the biggest the most
impressive city they've ever seen the
weight lotawana is carried out to them
and team lenguas makes history in an
awkwardly gracious meeting between
worlds well Texoma then launches into a
flowery Nahuatl that's up for
interpretation but I think we'll come
back to haunt the city take the word for
city state from earlier I'll dip it
it literally means water hill now listen
to this line from otic soma in Matsumoto
Betsy Madsen and motivic scene have the
same roots water and Hill plus the same
formal scene at the end of Malin Singh
it's your water sir and your Hill sir
he's symbolically offering the city to
Cortes well to master Malin check see
the Aztecs are addressing Tim Lang was
not as Cortes but as maligne Singh they
even painted the pair side by side in
their own codices with her as the
speaker from here the history of this
conquest turns more tactical than
linguistic or testings mo Texoma hostage
months of puppet rule are broken by a
brutal Spanish attack during the holiday
of bullsh got that unleashes an Aztec
uprising which ends in the death of
Montezuma and many many Spaniards and
allies as they flee the city regrouping
in plush gala team lengua secures more
reinforcements and performs a linguistic
trick see Cortez interpreted Montezuma's
poetic speech in matzah nimble Tibet
scene as him handing the Empire over if
Spain was the rifle master that makes
the Aztecs officially a people in
rebellion thus follows the vengeful
recruiting of even more allies and the
outbreak of a major plague the Empire
shatters into basically a civil war in
central Mexico that implodes into a
final siege on Tenochtitlan a siege that
lasts the summer of 1521 costs hundreds
of thousands of lives and ends with the
city in ruins
Cuauhtemoc the final waitlet juanny
is spared only to be executed by Cortez
a few years later before his death he
speaks out with aztec defiance
Oh captain Malinche long have I
understood have I known your false words
duplicity today in Mexico that's the
kind of sting that the name Malinche has
Mylene Kista you'd trade your own
culture for a taste of something foreign
but heroes villains or players in a
clash between two great empires
translators were key in the conquest of
Mexico mulling seeing above all I'll be
back soon to compare Aztec versus Mayan
grammar and unravel a peculiar
linguistic secret about mulling scenes
Mexico stick around and subscribe for
language
[Music]
you